[Music]
i'm so excited to share this with you
we've been working on this for almost a
year now and we're finally announcing it
and we're announcing it through this
essay so i'm going to read this essay
for you this is our right here right now
segment on the minimalist podcast and
this essay is called
this much debt
is gross
ryan our society has a problem
most people are financially illiterate
and it's not even their fault
because we don't learn how to manage
money as kids we are easily convinced by
corporations to go into debt as young
adults buying things we don't need with
money we don't have to impress people we
don't like
when we spend then we spend years mired
in the mess we've made credit card debt
student loans car payments and myriad
other ways we borrow from our future
the average indebted american household
has 97
775 dollars in non-mortgage debt
how gross is that what say that again
the average indebted american household
has 97
775 dollars
in non-mortgage related debt so a car
could be in there car credit card
student loans over three big ones
everything about your mortgage yeah
that's those are the three big that's
actually in fact it's that number is
from those three things added up
together
yes
but if we can teach students if we can
teach kids how to stay out of debt then
we can end the suffering that is
compounded by debt and that's what ryan
and i want to do today that's why the
minimalists we are partnering with
ramsey education this year in 2022
to bring the foundations in personal
finance curriculum get this
to every school in our hometown dayton
ohio every school thank you would you be
willing to help us
and here's what we're asking for so over
the the past decade the minimalists and
our audience have contributed to nine
philanthropic projects including
building two orphanages providing relief
to american hurricane victims
constructing an elementary school and
establishing a non-profit grocery co-op
in one of the largest food deserts in
the united states and now this year with
your help
we're going to teach
personal finance to every middle and
high school student in dayton every
middle school student every high school
student in dayton and if we reach our 40
000 goal quickly we can expand this to
other cities all across the united
states
now the foundations and personal finance
teaches students proven money principles
that will set them up for a debt-free
life
the problem is many schools don't have
the resources they need to provide this
curriculum to their students and that's
how we and you can help
you can purchase the curriculum for just
one child and it's really inexpensive or
you can do it for multiple children if
you're feeling really generous but 25
provides the curriculum for one middle
school student
45 provides the curriculum for one high
school student
and if you don't have 25 bucks or 45
bucks
then five dollars you can donate as
little as five dollars
and you can help provide the curriculum
for some students and that's awesome
could you imagine if we had this when we
were kids it'd be the best oh it would
have saved me like 10 years of like pain
and anguish man all that suffering of
all the crappy financial decisions i've
made yeah so by contributing you'll help
these kids start their adult life
the right way
and like i said we're going to try to
expand this to other schools as well
beyond the city of dayton but we want to
start with our hometown yeah and then
we'll we'll move on beyond there and we
could really use your help we we're not
going to make any money from this
personally in fact i got a whole thing
about this but if you want to donate the
minimalists.com
education that'll take you right to the
page there's a lot of frequently asked
questions there there's the progress bar
etc etc and seriously if you spend 70
bucks here you can provide curriculum
for one middle school student one high
school student you're literally just
going in there providing the curriculum
for a student or with a forty thousand
dollar donation
you can yeah provided for the whole city
exactly in fact you wouldn't even have
to be that do that much and here's why
to be clear the minimalists won't earn
any money from this project i just
wanted to put that out there so it
doesn't sound like we're making
i'm out we're actually gonna lose money
on it i know i'm gonna explain why here
in a second every penny that you donate
literally every penny a hundred percent
will be used for student curriculum
in fact ryan and i are personally
donating 2500
of our own money to fund the first 100
students
so if you want to help us change the
future for these kids the
minimalists.com education if you go
there
you'll find commonly asked questions
you'll find all the details you'll find
our fundraiser progress bar and after
you donate we'll email you with updates
about the impact of your contribution
the impact that it's having on actual
students lives now ryan i want to go
through this real quick since we're
doing this we have the foundations and
personal finance curriculum i went
through this this course which by the
way it's a 13-hour course i didn't go
through the whole thing but i went
through all the curriculum yeah because
i want to make sure that as we're
helping them create this for for the
students
that it was something i was 100 behind
because i know i'm behind dave ramsey's
method and but i want to make sure that
this is going to help and not only will
it help but i would have been interested
in this as a high schooler
because it's not here's the credits and
debits molten rock is magma like it's
actual stuff i want to want to learn
right and so here's the 13 different
things that the contents of this course
you have introduction to personal
finance you have budgeting you have
saving money you have credit versus
debit you have consumer awareness career
readiness college planning financial
services the role of insurance income
and taxes housing and real estate
investing and retirement global
economics but they do it in a way so
that's there's like really four parts to
the whole curriculum there are videos
which you know in high school you would
have much rather watch videos than just
read a bunch of textbooks right oh yeah
so you have videos for every one of
these
you have student textbooks that you
could follow along but the videos are
the main thing you have teachers guides
and you have activities for students so
they're actually engaged in the learning
yeah 25 bucks you can bring this
curriculum to a student 45 you can bring
it to a high school student if you want
to help the minimalists.com
education we'd really really appreciate
if you contribute ryan and i rarely ask
for anything for ourselves from you
we want to help these kids
well not borrow from their future yeah
so you can brighten their future today
for 25 bucks did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free